in this breakthrough you could say that
physicists have taken a new angle on
subatomic particles called neutrinos
neutrinos are born in nuclear
interactions and they come in three
different types or flavors they also
change from one flavor to another as
they zip along at just about light speed
these so called neutrino oscillations
are described by six parameters the
three mass differences among the
neutrinos and three abstract mixing
angles this year physicists with the
daya Bay neutrino reactor experiments in
China measured the last of these
parameters an angle known as theta one
three they showed that it was about nine
degrees the fact that all three of the
mixing angles are not zero means that
it's possible that neutrinos and
antineutrinos
oscillate slightly differently that in
turn could help explain how the universe
generated so much matter in so little
antimatter so this result really shows
that neutrino physics has a very bright
future it's also the most important
physics result ever to come out of China
some physicists say so for those reasons
the measurement of the last neutrino
mixing angle is one of our top ten
breakthroughs in beer
you